[Music]
well after back-to-back wins over the
kings the golden knights keeping the
road trip going now taking on the
anaheim ducks kevin martin joins us live
in studio with highlights from tonight's
matchup
well brian the golden knights in the
golden knights short history they've had
the duck's number
in 17 all-time meetings between these
two teams vegas has won
14 of them but as we all know anything
can happen on any given night in the nhl
and vegas wasn't taking anaheim lightly
the golden knights looking to extend
their win streak to five games while the
ducks trying to win three in a row for
the first time all season
it was scoreless after one but it took
vegas nine seconds in the second period
to find twine riley smith drives to the
net
will be william carlson picking up the
loose puck to put his squad up on the
golden knights on the move
chandler stevenson right down the middle
his 10th of the season
2-nothing vgk still in the second and
check out this play by nick wall records
the steal
and sends it upstairs to make it 3-0
to the third and braden mcnabb getting
in on the action firewood inning gives
the golden knights
a four goal lead and that would do it as
vegas out shoots the ducks
51-16 for their fifth straight win robin
leonard recording his 60th
career shutout as the vgk looked to keep
pace with the first place avalanche
well that's been our goal and you know i
give our group credit i mean
colorado hasn't i think they've lost one
in their last
19 or 20 or something like that so
you know the fact we're still hanging
around i think is a testament to
our resilience uh here to stay in the
fight and
win the games we need to win a very
impressive win for vegas we'll have more
on this domination coming up in sports